what was great here was Roger Rajan of
the Bank of India ten years ago stole
the show
take us back ten years and then move us
forward through the fault lines that
Rajan sees well 2005 was the year Alan
Greenspan was retiring and everybody
came to Jackson Hole to talk about what
a great central banker he was the best
central banker in the history of the
world except for the Chicago Booth
schools Raghuram Rajan who came to the
conference and said hey everybody out
there you're ignoring fault lines that
are developing in the global economy and
we're going to have trouble ahead he
wasn't invited back again until this
year now he's the head of the Reserve
Bank of India and Bretta Greeley and I
sat down and talked to him about it he
said basically you know I still see some
problems in the world today but it's no
longer the responsibility of central
banks I would say we're in period of our
trust row growth it would be better if
we grew faster I I would also say that
central banks have pretty much done what
they could do it's not a view that's
universally held by central bankers but
but I think in general across the world
central banks have done pretty much what
what they capable of now others have to
step up interestingly enough of course
that doesn't apply to his bank because
as he pointed out on a panel with
Stanley Fischer mark and Vito constancio
from the ECB he's the only one out there
who has to lower the inflation where are
the fault lines as we move to jobs day
and we moved to September 17th Raghu in
financial economics has set the tone
that book is iconic where are those
fault lines well you've still got
overvalued equity markets in a lot of
the world and then a lot of hot money
had flown into emerging markets that may
go out now a lot of it has been going
out and that's been causing some of the
stock market dislocations character with
us as well with terrific perspective on
Friday as Mike was out in Jackson Hole
what did you learn from Professor
Fischer well he there was a subtle shot
across New York Fed president Dudley's
Friday afternoon where he said basically
I wouldn't say whether it's less likely
or more likely that we would raise rates
going
into the September meeting whereas
Dudley said it seemed less likely in
that interview if that was a little bit
of like let's not react to the latest
apology let's bring the show to a total
halt why does this language this
semantics matter how do we get Carl
Rekha Donna to less likely more likely
several few well it's it's the world of
fed watching and you know the words are
parsed very closely but the fact that
Fischer chose the exact same words as
Dudley and then kind of rolled it back
you know what's a very I mean come on
this is like Robert Rubin probabilistic
well basically he said it's an open
question in his speech on Saturday he
outlined the two parameters of what the
Fed is looking at him in one is
inflation and he's reassured the
audience that as he said there is good
reason to believe that inflation will
move higher as the forces holding down
inflation dissipate further in other
words their forecast is inflation is
still going to go higher and then jobs
he said we now wait the results of the
August employment survey which are due
to be published on September fourth and
that specific reference has everybody
looking to Friday as the key to whether
the Fed moves if we get a good number
then the bets are all going to start
moving in the direction of a Fed will
Volvo Carly although this last for
August we've had lower than expected
jobs numbers seasonal adjustment problem
that could be a PR problem for them all
right potentially so Dudley highlighted
the notion of the the employment report
and said that basically this will be
somewhat stale data because the
Employment Survey period was beers or
all of the reasons financial market
volatility picked up so I think instead
rather than a jobs report I think
policymakers are just watching financial
market developments and they want to see
if the volatility continues and if
sentiment starts the sour either at
households at the household level or the
team if we're still seeing the markets
gyrate then they may hold off if not
they all to a person back told us out
there pay attention to the bar the data
have given them the economy they need to
initiate liftoff so it's really trying
to well the keys
jobs Borgias 220 what we need to see
Michael or what you know what did you
infer from what President Fisher was
saying that we would need to see for
them to hold off
well the lat the average miss over the
last four years is about 44,000 so if
you came in at 180 they always get
revised higher but that's gonna be a
sort of a visual problem for the markets
and for the Fed if it comes in that low
they're thinking it's gonna come in you
know better than 200,000 but that's
maybe a demarcation point for people to
start to worry I think they like 200,000
or better
I think 175 or greater they're still
gonna clear you know dip below 150
there's the problem what's it mean for
the markets I got the futures negative
18 I got oil trying to come down again
not 44 35 Mike McKee whatever they do or
whatever the jobs report is how would
the market react after what we've seen
the last four weeks well if the job
report is strong then it's gonna start
pricing in a Fed move and you'll
probably see bond yields move a little
higher stocks could go lower that's been
the pattern the interesting thing is
what happens if the Fed doesn't do
anything on September 17th then we're
gonna see a big rally in the yellow and
put gets it back into place and people
start to worry again about the Fed and
whether they'll ever move